willkommen zur heutigen sitzung der
vierten sitzung dieses semester heute
haben wir uns als thema das internet als
handlungsraum und grundrecht
fragezeichen vorgenommen dieses
fragezeichen gilt sowohl für das
internet als handlungsraum ob es das ist
muss man diskutieren aber natürlich auch
für die frage nach dem grund recht dass
das internet darstellen könnte
vielleicht sogar auch sollte und die
frage wie existieren wir im internet das
ist eine spannende frage die hängt
natürlich ganz entschieden davon ab wie
wir das internet bestimmen ist das
internet nur konsum medium dann
existieren wir gar nicht im internet
sondern irgendwie außerhalb des
internets von gier laden uns die daten
aus dem internet herunter also wir
nutzen das internet wie so eine quelle
und zapfen sie an sind aber nicht im
internet drin wenn wir jetzt uns aber
eben das problem des datenschutzes und
der privatsphäre überlegen ich mach oben
rechts und links zur letzten sitzung
hinein wo wir uns dieses problem genauer
angesehen haben dann scheint es schon
der fall sein dass wir auch im internet
zumindest vorkommen oder spuren
hinterlassen das werde erster schritt
der nächste schritt wäre dass wir nicht
nur dort wo hinterlassen weil
irgendwelche plattform oder programme
davon abziehen sondern dass wir selbst
aktiv im internet auch nicht nur spuren
hinterlassen seine handlungen vollziehen
und auch das scheint mir recht plausibel
zu sein darüber müssen sie aber dann
natürlich noch gemeinsam diskutieren
also wie existieren wir wenn wir
überhaupt existieren im internet nur als
daten oder vielleicht sogar als
virtuelle akteurinnen und akteure
jenseits von blusen avataren pseudonymen
oder anonymen existenzen diese fragen
wollen wir heute sprechen
diskutieren und die leitfrage lautet
eben inwiefern ist das internet mehr als
nur ein konsum medium und inwiefern ist
das internet ein virtueller handlung
von hingeben entschieden die frage auch
nach den moralischen gesetzen die dort
gelten sollten ab und eben auch die
frage wie wir darin existieren
existieren wir
digital und virtuell im internet und
falls ja wie
auf eine andere weise als unsere
physische körperlich existenz das ist
die spannende frage und natürlich last
but not least inwiefern sollte jeder
mensch ein recht auf internet-zugang
haben das hängt auch ganz entschieden
davon ab wie wird die erste frage und
die zweite frage
beantworten ich habe eine klare meinung
dazu aber leider aufhören wenn er noch
kommen ja jetzt geht es also um die
ethik des internets und erstmals stellt
sich natürlich die frage was ist
überhaupt das internet robert dreyfuss
ein recht bekannter philosoph
nordamerikanischer philosoph aus
kalifornien der university of berkeley
kalifornien
der hat eine ein buch darüber
geschrieben das ist schon ein bisschen
älter an die internet- und der schreibt
die internet ist eine justin new
technology kann den menschen in diesen
you type of techno version one that
brings out the very essence of
technology also das internet ist nicht
nur eine neue erfindung eine neue
technische innovation sondern sie ist
das paradigma
der technologie grundsätzlich ist als
eine ausgezeichnete
technologie
sei noch ein zitat da der dass jetzt
dieses immer sehr kritisch betrachtet
also über dreyfus argumentiert immer so
wir sollten nie vergessen dass wir
eigentlich körperlich existieren und das
internet und der virtuelle raum ist ihm
immer so prinzipiell and körperlichkeit
spielt unser körper oder genauer gesagt
unser leib als unser lebendiger körper
beliebter körper nicht mehr so eine
große rolle das betrifft jetzt die frage
die wir uns vorgenommen hatten wie
existieren wir im virtuellen
handlungsraum des internets und jetzt
sagt er folgendes venture cyberspace
also das internet sagte der cyber space
and leave behind motion intuitiv
streetwear label im bade zelt in der
bayarena freedom never before they wirte
juni ist bereit etwas sehen teilen das
ist sehr religiös some of the cities
aber built to make sense of things so es
tut dies technisch relevante relevant
aber sense of the series of sex and the
city von learning in ihrem maxi und
bridget gibst a sense of the reality of
things voerde mit beat 'em torwart
christoph jenny commitment and
solutions of what with me to life
ja das ist jetzt in eine scheune stark
diese so eine antithese dazu er sagt im
internet oder cyberspace heute könnten
wir sagen im metaversum
verlieren wie oder lassen wir hinter uns
zurück unsere emotionale intuitive
situierte verletzliche verkörperte
subjektivität und gewinnen da tut
natürlich dadurch 9 raus wenn wir nicht
mehr so sehr von seinem körper
angewiesen sind auf unsere physische
existenz die uns ja raum zeitlich
begrenzt
wir können überall seien in kurzer zeit
das können wir physisch und dann
verlieren wir sagt dreyfus auch vermögen
kapazitiv nämlich dass wichtige von
weniger wichtigem zu unterscheiden und
das ist tatsächlich ein problem wird
weil wir es hier mit einer datenflut zu
tun haben das internet liefert uns eine
unendliche fülle an nicht nur daten ich
hatte ja daten als und interpretierte
informationen verstanden darüber können
wir auch noch mal diskutieren das
verhältnis von daten informationen
information scheint mir noch
spezifischer sein oder schon semantisch
interpretiert oder bedeutungsvoller als
bloße taten wir müssen aus daten
informationen gewinnen daten als solche
selten ohne basis auf der wir dann
weiter voranschreiten also wir verlieren
denn sinn für das wichtige im internet
und das liegt sicherlich erstmal auf der
hand weil die es mit einer darstellung
zu tun haben ja und dann sagte auch noch
ein grip
also wir verlieren den welt bezug
und unseren sinn verriet die
wirklichkeit der dinge ja das ist die
frage ist das internet wirklich nur eine
simulation oder eine anti wirklichkeit
eine gegenwelt oder ist das internet
nicht durch eine eigene realität so dass
wir vielleicht unseren sinn für die
realität von dingen nicht nur
verlieren
sondern er weiter ja also meine these
wäre im metaversum im cyberspace im
internet wie wir es auf immerhin da
verlieren wenn ich unseren sinn für die
wirklichkeit wir verlieren nicht im
griff sondern wir erweitern der zugriff
also kein wirklichkeit entzug eine
flucht in eine parallelwelt die wir nur
scheinwelt ist sondern es 1 1 in
wirklichkeit bezug nimmt sind eine
erweiterung die der nicht in
kommissionen oder wer als alternative zu
unserem physischen welt bezug stehen
mussten als eine erweiterung
ja er sagt es wird sie könnten versucht
sein
wirkliche entscheidungen oder dieses
risiko wirklich uns zu entscheiden zu
vermeiden und eben auch so den sinn für
das bedeutsame in unserem leben
verlieren ja das sind große themen der
meaning of our life die bedeutung des
lebens der sinn des lebens könnte der
durch das internet gefährdet zahlen auch
ein spannendes thema das man auch in
essays oder hausarbeiten nach am rande
verwenden könnte also solche zitate wie
hier eignet sich immer um daran auch zu
argumentieren dafür begegnen deswegen
habe ich dieses zitat aufgebracht was
sie gerne auch mal wieder selbst
verwenden können ja also das gute fragen
es hängt eben ganz entschieden davon ab
wie wir das immer nicht verstehen und
drüber dreyfus versteht das internet als
technologie
frage ist sollten wir mich noch darüber
hinweggehen hinausgehen und das internet
nicht nur als technologie zum medium
sondern eben als virtuellen
handlungsraum also als eigene virtuelle
realität verstehen das möchte ich die
frage möchte ich noch mal so einen
virtuellen raum her werfen da möchte ich
einen weiteren wichtigen begriff im
kontext unserer fragestellung
präsentieren nämlich den des onlive
diesen begriff hat luciano florida in
seinem buch die vierte revolution
geprägt florida hat hier einen ganz
klaren informations theoretischen zugang
er spricht von einer info sphäre infos
fähre ist eben die sphäre die aus
digitalen und analogen information
besteht dass also die umfassende
informations wäre die im grunde genommen
unsere gesamte wirklichkeit nachfrage
ausmachen ich persönlich finde diesen
zugang sehr sympathisch weil er einfach
zeigt dass das internet sich einfach an
schließt es keine gegen welzel
fortsetzung unseres slogan physischen
informationsraum ich würde nur kritisch
einwenden dass die konzentration auf die
information allein der vollen bedeutung
der virtuellen realität mit der wir es
hier zu tun haben nicht gerechnet weil
informations theoretische zugänge in
meinen augen den handlungs aspekt also
das dynamisch dasjenige was sich
vollzieht zwischen den informationen
nicht verständlich machen kann wenn wir
im internet agieren durch virtuelle
akteure oder sonstige instanzen dann ist
das sicherlich auch im sinne von
informationen zu verstehen aber es ist
eben nicht mehr nur information ist es
auch informationen dass wir jetzt zu
diesem zeitpunkt im
virtuellen autopsie lawn etwas getan
haben das können wir im sinne von daten
oder meta daten beschreiben oder
festhalten aber darin geht ja die
virtuelle handlung nicht aus wir tun ja
was und dieser dynamische kraft aspekte
auch inbegriff des virtuellen die
virtuelle realität bewahrt ist der kommt
dazu kurz in meine augen deswegen würde
ich argumentieren nicht auf den begriff
der information abzustellen sondern auf
dem griff der virtuellen realität jedoch
hat flori die sehr zurecht und sehr
wirklich treffend diesen begriff des
onlive geprägt ich möchte mal hier auch
ein zitat vorlesen die digitale online
welt weitet sich in die analoge auf
flyern welt hinein aus und verschmilzt
mit ja dieses jüngste phänomen von
firmiert unter diversen bezeichnungen
wie ubiquitäre es
computing-umgebung intelligenz das
internet der dinge und bei pigmenten die
erweiterung der dinge durch das netz ich
verwende dafür lieber den ausdruck
onlive erfahrung sie ist oder wird das
nächste stadium der entwicklung im
informationszeitalter
sein wir leben immer mehr ein onlive
das ist als auch ganz spannend
diese neue erweiterung die wir dadurch
erfahren durch die virtuelle existenz
und noch ein zitat die allmähliche
informatisierung von artefakten und
ganze soziale umgebung also hier sieht
man wieder dass flori die stark von
informations begriff ausgeht ich würde
eher sagen die virtualisierung bedeutet
dass es schwere zu verstehen wie das
leben in vor digitalen zeiten gewesen
ist in der nächsten zukunft wird der
unterschied zwischen online- offline-
immer noch weiter verwischen und dann
ganz verschwinden schon jetzt hat es
beispielsweise wenig sinn zu fragen ob
man online oder offline sei wenn man
beim fahren den anweisungen eines
navigationssystems volk das seine daten
echtzeit aktualisiert mit der gleichen
frage wird jemand nichts anzufangen
wissen dass seine e mails abruft während
er mit einem fahrerlosen auto unterwegs
ist das von einem gps gesteuert wird
also hier sehen wir wieder konkrete
beispiele und das ist ganz wichtig
angesichts dieser diskussion um die
neuen medien wir müssen immer konkret
werden meine kritik hier eben wirklich
nur
der informations beschränkte zugriff
darauf der unsere handlungen die ganze
dynamik die sich von zieht nicht adäquat
fassen lässt in meinen augen
deshalb spricht jetzt flori die von
einer generation z also nicht mehr die
generation y 3 zu der so diese
vorherige generation zählte sind die
generation z die jetzt dieses onlive
lebt sagt das ist der generation z
unmöglich sein dürfte sich ein leben
außerhalb der info sphäre vorzustellen
liegt dramatisch gesagt daran dass infos
fähren nach und nach jede andere
wirklichkeit aufsaugt die generation zkm
onlive zur welt ja sie die teilnehmenden
jetzt dieses seminares könnten
größtenteils die dieser generation z zu
zählen sein vielleicht auch noch zu der
generation y oder
jedenfalls die nächsten würde für really
sagen die können gar nicht mehr anders
als onlive zu leben
dh die virtuelle realität hat sich hier
sehr in ihr leben einbezogen
natürlich könnte man jetzt sagen
virtuell handeln wir doch auch immer
schon zum beispiel durch geld geld ist
doch auch virtuell tatsächlich es bietet
sich auch an diese fusion von den neuen
medien zu herkömmlichen physischen
realität nicht über den informations
begriff herzustellen wie für ids möchten
sondern eben über den virtuellen
realitäts begriff das ist auch eine
möglichkeit aber auch hier können wir an
unsere bisherige lebenswelt anschließen
die das internet ist nur eine
erweiterung der virtuellen realität
während geld und soziale institution
bereits in unserer physischen welt auch
virtuelle realität dargestellt haben
spannende frage das hier ist jetzt eine
soziologische frage eine psychologische
fragen vielleicht kommt wie in zukunft
die
generation mit dem online leben umgehen
werde und wie sich das online leben mit
dem offline leben zueinander verhält
hier noch ein letztes zitat als
konsequenz der information hier unsere
alltäglichen umgebung leben manchen
menschen in hyper geschichtlichen
gesellschaften schon jetzt ein onlive in
einer in zunehmendem maße
synchronisierten die lokalisierten und
aufeinander abgestimmten infos fehler
auch wenn sie hier in von einer
optimistischen warte aus das freundliche
gesicht der globalisierung erkennen
ließen sollten wir uns keinen illusionen
hingeben die weitreichend und inklusiv
die evolution von informations
gesellschaften ist oder sein wird wenn
wir keine lösung finden ist damit zu
rechnen dass die digitale kluft ein
abgrund wird und neue formen der
ausgrenzung und trennung entstehen lässt
zwischen den menschen die sich in der
info sphäre ansiedeln können und denen
die das nicht können zwischen den
eingeweihten und dem nicht eingeweihten
zwischen den reichlich mit informationen
versorgen und den von ihr abgeschnitten
das nur die welt verändern und die
globale gesellschaft in langen stehender
oder sich vergrößern der geographische
sozioökonomischer um kulturelle gräben
in eine generation z plus und eine
generation z - spalten und es wird jetzt
natürlich wieder die frage danach aus ob
das internet als ein grundrecht gelten
sollte das jedem menschen zur verfügung
steht so dass wir eben diese kulturellen
gräben zwischen generation z plus und
generation z - jedem vermeiden könnten
wenn wir das in unseren gesetzen
verankert
dann könnte dieses problem nicht
auftreten das ließe sich ganz einfach
realisieren wir können darüber natürlich
diskutieren dass man einfach so wie man
menschen eben verschiedene andere dinge
gewehrt eben auch ein entsteht im
internet zugang gewährt durch die
ausstattung die kosten muss der
ausstattung mit mobilen endgeräten die
dafür geeignet in einer flächendeckenden
versorgung mit internet am besten
natürlich kabellos über satellit und
jetzt möchte ich auf das metaversum
eingehen das ist jetzt dieser neue
begriff der vielleicht sogar den begriff
des cyberspace
ja ablösen wird ich bringe hier mal eine
kurze definition aus wikipedia die tiefe
aktionen die ändern sich ständig das
metabolische englisch wetterfest ist ein
kollektiver virtueller raum damals
wieder den raum begriff cyberspace der
durch die konvergenz von virtuell
erweiterter physische realität und
physisch persistent im virtuellen raum
entsteht einschließlich der zum aller
virtuellen welten der erweiterten
realität in des internets es ist also
eigentlich der nachfolge begriff von
floridas infos fähre das wort metaversum
ist ein koffer wort aus der vorserie
meter in der bedeutung von jenseits und
universum also den jederzeit überall der
begriff wird üblicherweise verwendet um
das konzept einer zukünftigen
integration des internets zu beschreiben
das aus persistenten gemeinsam genutzten
virtuellen 3d räumen besteht die zu
einem wahrgenommenen virtuellen
universum verbunden sind in abgrenzung
dazu besteht ein massively multiplayer
online role playing game mmo rpg
aus einer einzigen welt metaversum
können user die welt mitgestalten und
dort leben lernen und arbeiten und
feiern so preist das ganze methan oder
facebook an jedenfalls wird ihr klar
hier wird das internet nicht mehr nur
als ein virtueller konsum raum oder als
ein bloßes medium konsum medium selbst
als den inbegriff des der technologie
wie bei robert dreyfuss noch verstanden
sondern als ein virtueller
handlungsrahmen ja ein virtueller alltag
könnte man eine virtuelle lebenswelt
muss man wirklich sagen sollen hier
unten ja auch steht neben lernen und
arbeiten und sogar feiern das ist unsere
lebenswelt dass unser alltag das ist
nichts womit wir uns mal einklinken für
fünf minuten um e mails abzurufen
sondern wir sind permanent darin und das
ist irgendwie lebensweltliche betrunken
ja mittag kennen sie schon die facebook
neue das neue gesicht von facebook
und natürlich auch von diesen anderen
unternehmen die meter plattform
credit to business ist matter ehemals
facebook ist ein us-amerikanisches
technologieunternehmen der gesellschaft
führen unter anderem die sozialen
netzwerke facebook und instagram die
instant messaging apps whatsapp
messenger sowie oculus ein hersteller
von virtual reality technologie ja große
finanzielle kommerzielle werte sind
damit verbunden und das macht das ganze
natürlich problematisch weil wieso
sollte unser onlive unsere virtuelle
lebenswelt bestimmt werden von
kommerziellen interessen
sollten wir dabei nie vergessen hier
versuchten unternehmen in alle unsere
lebensbereich einzudringen und das macht
das ganze eben auch ins privat schutz
datenschutzgründen sehr problematisch
also hier sehen wir wieder den bezug vom
metaversum zur problem des datenschutzes
zu privatsphäre das metaversum wäre wenn
es kommerziell bestimmt ist nicht mehr
eine privatsphäre das würden wir damit
einkaufen wenn es kommerziell oder
sofern es kommerziell noch interessiert
ist das heißt hier könnten wir jetzt
sagen ja wir sollten ein recht auf
internet-zugang haben aber bitteschön
unabhängig von kommerziellen interessen
es wäre doch geradezu ja
gleichzeitig einen unternehmen
das recht oder die möglichkeit zu
gestehen
uns einen virtuellen handlungsraum zur
verfügung zu stellen wer kontrolliert
das heißt wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
es ein grundrecht auf internet geben
sollte dann bitte nicht garantiert von
meta oder facebooks anbiete garantiert
von google möglichst unabhängigen
institutionen staatlichen institutionen
vielleicht sogar globalen demokratisch
im idealfall noch gewählten
institutionen die völlig transparent
auch transparenten ziehen atrium und wo
wir mit bestehen können also wieder weg
von diesen losen passiven konsum medium
hin zur aktiven mitgestaltung des recht
was eben auch unser grundrecht anklagt
wir müssen als nutzerinnen nutzer
mitbestimmen wer die infrastruktur zur
verfügung stellt wir müssen einblick
darin erhalten welche daten von uns
abgezockt werden will müssen datenschutz
stimmungen mitbestimmen die auch das den
virtuellen raum betreffen und das ist
natürlich dann nicht der fall oder nicht
in diesem maße der fall wenn es sich
hierbei um kommerzielle interessen
gehandelt das möchte ich als immer zu
bedenken geben diese ganze idee des
metaversum ist noch wirtschaftlich
ökonomisch getrieben wir sollten wenn
wir argumentieren dass wir ein
grundrecht als internet haben sollten
dann auch gleich im gleichen zuge
daraufhin dringen dass das ganze nicht
mehr kommerziell ist kommerziell
realisiert das möchte ich ihnen nur hier
auch zur debatte stehen jetzt gibt es
hier von meta ein
vorzeigeprojekt nämlich weiß und rot ich
muss zu gestehen ich habe ja nicht
gespielt mein rechner würde dafür
ausreichend aber ich habe noch nicht die
die endgeräte dafür da braucht man jetzt
mal wissen solche
3d brillen und sonstige interaktions
endgeräte die praktisch gewissermaßen
unsere unseren zugang dazu ermöglichen
und natürlich ist es hier auch wieder
ein kommerzielles interesse dahinter ja
meter möchte dass wir dies endgeräte
kaufen diese nicht gerade günstig ja
vielleicht lege ich mir mal als zu uns
mal auszuprobieren wir brauchen diese
drei betrieb die brille oder
irgendwelche endgeräte darin überhaupt
interagieren zu können hat das ist
natürlich ganz klar wieder kommerziell
interessiert
entgelte brauchen wir bislang noch die
frage ist ob wir irgendwann vielleicht
gar keine endgeräte wir brauchen also
wir ob wir irgendwie anders
angeschlossen werden können an das
internet
the world formula
facebook reisen ist free virtual reality
online video game wo es im integrierten
crm-system
development fonds
volksschule swift and or king's quest to
das sind jetzt diese 3d brille diese
oculus gift optimus ist diese firma die
diese geräte herstellen etwas realized
in die usa und kanada zu tippen
oder ein bisschen banal
2008 an invite only the face quelle ist
in der wikipedia also ganz neu brandneu
ich glaube ich werde mich da mal ein
bisschen oben sehen muss ich eigentlich
wenig davon spreche soll ich tatsächlich
nicht nur in diesem herkömmlichen
internet- oder youtube was natürlich
auch wieder
zu alfabet gehört was natürlich auch
kommerziell interessiert ist sondern ich
sollte mich auch mal damit auch
tatsächlich nur von einem meter
gesichtspunkt also einen reden übers
einmal an wie man menschen bezugspunkt
damit befassen ja jetzt gibt es
natürlich hier auch ethische probleme
das führt wieder zurück auf unser
seminar auf unserem seminar frage wenn
wir jetzt da interagieren in diesem
virtuellen handlungsraum in diesem
metaversum dann interagieren wir darin
natürlich auch auf eine moralisch
manchmal bedenkliche weiß leider einige
tun das und zwar richtig auch aus
wikipedia ein ereignis mal kurz
vorstellen
november
2009 ab beta user report beruht also
belästigt und reisen prozent aller user
support kontakt mit respawn at that
there is to
say that used to protect and sales von
interaction with others in the great and
i 2000 ready to meter in response to die
instanz edita manager personal beim
return
venues mit invisible virtual berry
und avatar event in jesus von coming
griffin vorsieht auf einen avatar
label switching und top of excess
features that makes users hens dieser
tiefe got to close to the
plans für all seine ausfuhr users to
change des saals auf discounter in the
future the boundaries feature ist
seminaristen features wie sie als chat
encryption
stable und change das eis auf dem baum
radics ist ja jetzt kamen hier manche
virtuelle avatare anderen zu nahe
an den privatraum also praktisch in den
virtuellen privaten da haben sich leute
bedrängt gefühlt belästigt gefühlt
virtuell betrinken
jetzt hat facebook oder meter in
reaktion darauf einen virtuellen ja
privatraum eine
sicherheitszone
privatsphäre könnte man sagen virtuell
noch mal realisiert die komfortzone
praktisch die eben dadurch
virtuell ja was jetzt simuliert wurde
oder sogar
realisiert wird eine saison und ist
jetzt entscheidende frage handelt es
sich jetzt bei horizon bereits bei
diesen vorfeld dass da leute bedrängt
wurde und sich beträgt gefühl gehabt
handelt es sich dabei nur um
simulationen sind es also simulierte
formen von belästigung von bedrängung
von eindringen in die komfortzone gibt
es so was wie eine komfortzone rein
privat zonen gar nicht kann es sie gar
nicht geben im virtuellen handelsraum
oder eben doch und was folgt daraus für
die moralischen der wert dieser ihr
offenbar handlungen im virtuellen
handlungsraum des metaversum es ja das
ist eine spannende frage können wir uns
können wir da strafbar werden oder
moralische regeln widersprechen dann
müssen wir erstmal überlegen welche
moralischen regeln dort
es kommt hier sehen wir sind mitten in
der philosophie warte um die ethik nicht
der digitalisierung weil das hier nicht
mehr rein technisch zu verstehen jede
der digitalität geht es um die
virtuellen realitäten die auf der
digitalen digitaltechnik energien ja
also das sind jetzt die fragen die ich
schon ein bisschen vorweggenommen haben
aber es sollten metaversum auch
moralische regeln gelten so wie in der
analogen behält und wie sollten sie
genau beschaffen sein oder sollte für
das metaversum wie auch das internet
gelten ähnlich sind groß wilder
virtueller westen der virtuelle westen
oder noch nicht und irgendwann das
entspannte vorgegangen müssen wir
natürlich dass die welt als einen
handlungsraum bestimmen wir können wird
dann die ethische bedeutung des
internets angemessen bestimmt wenn wir
es als ein virtuelles raum verstehen
diese zwei bedingungen
vorausgesetzt müssen virtuelle realität
stärker als nur eine grosse simulation
illusion oder fiktion verstehen denn
diesen kommt nur eine schwache ethische
gedauert hat wenn wir etwas simulieren
ein prozess ignorieren dann sind wir da
nicht ganz bei der wirklichkeit das
heißt oder auch bei fiktionen wenn die
fiktion entwerfen dann sind wir da
eigentlich immer im freiraum
künstlerischen freiraum wir sehen dass
daran wenn wir bücher schreiben oder
mehr bücher veröffentlichen oder bücher
sehen die sehr problematische inhalte
haben
gewaltdarstellung aber immer nur fiktiv
oder auch sexuelle themen
die uns provozieren pornographisch usw
dann gehen die immer wieder eine debatte
wobei wo endet wo beginnt die
künstlerische freiheit wo beginnt die
die beginnen die moralischen grenzen der
fiktion immer wieder sehen wir dass die
gesetze die die richterinnen und richter
da sehr für die freiheit auch der kunst
argumentieren
das heißt wenn wir das mit diversen nur
als fiktionalen raum verstehen braucht
man simulierten haben als spieler haben
sozusagen nur als ein spiel dann haben
wir es immer noch mit anderen räumen zu
tun die nicht auf diese weise den
ethischen regeln unterliegen dem
iranischen gesetzen unterliegen wie in
unserer physischen analogen welt wir
sehen aber dass eben das internet immer
mehr doch zu einem relevanten
handlungsrahmen würze das wieder hier
auch offensichtlich moralische regeln
fordern können oder auch solche regeln
verletzen können die frage ist nur
welche regeln sind das müssen vor dem
hintergrund des internets als virtuellen
handlungsraum genauer bestimmen auch was
virtuelle handlungen sind das wird ihr
immer nur so getan als wüssten wir das
aber es ist gar nicht klar dabei spielt
insbesondere auch die raum und zeit
logik virtuelle realität eine zentrale
bedeutung also wo und wie und wann
handeln wir nicht mehr physisch nicht
mehr körperlich das steht fest aber ja
wie dann ja jetzt möchte ich beispiele
für virtuelle handlungsraum bringen wir
haben schon einst das beste gesehen dass
mit einer so aber natürlich auch soziale
plattformen und kanäle wie facebook
twitter youtube auch hier rezipieren wir
nicht nur sondern wir agieren durch sie
und in ihnen hinterlassen informationen
aber informationen zu hinterlassen ist
natürlich eine handlung
ja was ist jetzt eine virtuelle handlung
ja ich glaube virtuelle handlung sind
aktive und ich nur passive beziehungen
und verbindungen von informationen mit
bedeutung selbst wenn wir jetzt im
metaversum durch virtual reality
mit anderen personen uns näher ihnen
nähern so spielen wir doch darin
beziehungen her bedeutungsvolle
beziehungen
und das könnte man als eine handlung
verstehen
würde der handlung kündigten ohne
weiteres einen physischen subjekt
zugeschrieben werden natürlich sind sie
am ende von uns zunächst einmal
initiiert sondern sie können eben auch
mittels künstlicher intelligenz
externalisierung werden wir können
künstliche intelligenz nutzen um unsere
handlungen zu vergrössern zu
beschleunigen zu erweitern natürlich
stehen wir dann immer noch hinter der
künstliche intelligenz aber das ganze
wird viel komplexer durch den einsatz
künstlicher intelligenz auf künstliche
intelligenz gehen wir auch in der
nächsten sitzung noch genommen
ja jetzt stellt sich die frage nach der
personalen identität wird person können
virtuelle handlungsraum des internets
verschiedene rollen einnehmen
person können im internet anonym und
pseudo existierende todes meisten sie
können mit einem vpn client reihen deren
2 pia dresse verschleiern
wir können natürlich auch durch avatar
interagieren vor allem dann wenn es um
computer spiele geht und damit ist eben
weiterer punkt angezeigt auf denen wir
auch noch eigens angehen werden dass
computerspiele immer weniger nur als
spiel sichtbar werden als ein ernster
spielerei als zeitvertreib als
simulations- und dass wir im
computerspiel einen wirklichkeit bezug
realisieren und erlernen also
gewissermaßen
experimentell in der szene eines
bildungs prozesses virtuelle realität
einer und immer wieder verhandeln
natürlich immer auch im spielerischen
szenen aber so ist das eben mit dem
spiel friedrich schiller habt ihr auch
gesagt wir sind nur da ganz mensch wo
wir spielen also unsere freiheiten
existenz scheint mit dem spiel ganz eng
verbunden ist sagen wir sehen eben das
gerade durch das spiel solche neuen
formen personaler virtuelle existenz wie
eben durch avatare ein gefühl kommt ja
verhandelt dadurch kommt dem
computerspiel vor allem natürlich im
internet computerspielen eine ganz
bedeutende rolle zu es werden immer mehr
sehen dass die dass wir es mit mittels
des spiels ein virtueller handlungsraum
öffnen und dann eben diese handlungsraum
immer mehr konsolidiert wird immer
weniger als ein spiel überhaupt sichtbar
wird computerspiele werden also immer
weniger als konsum medien und immer mehr
als virtuelle handlungsräume sich dann
müssen erst spielerisch die grenzen des
virtuell handlungsrahmens ausloten bevor
dann diese handlungsraum wirklich
konsolidierten etabliert wird das als
ein prozess das geht nicht von heute auf
morgen ja das war es für die heutige
sitzung in der nächsten sitzung werden
wir uns mit dem thema künstliche
intelligenz und robotik befassen ich bin
heute stand darauf eingegangen ein
spannendes thema gerade auch dann wenn
es darum geht wie diese virtuelle
handlungsraum gefüllt wird wie er gelebt
wird und wer oder was eigentlich in
diesen virtuellen handlungsraum
existiert ja vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit ich bin gespannt auf die
diskussion gerne auch unten dann auf
youtube